I believe big institutions have unique
potential to create change and I believe
that we as individuals have unique power
to influence the direction that those
institutions take now these beliefs did
not come naturally to me because
trusting big institutions not really
part of my family legacy my mother
escaped North Korea when she was 10
years old to do so she had to elude
every big institution in her life
repressive governments occupying armies
and even armed border patrols later when
she decide she want to emigrate to the
United States she had to defy an entire
culture this is a girl's would never be
the best and brightest only because her
name happens to sound like a boys was
she able to finagle her way into the
government immigration exam to come to
the United States because of her bravery
and passion I've had all the
opportunities that she never did and
that has made my story so different
instead of running away from big
institutions I've actually run toward
them I've had the chance over the course
of my career to work for The Wall Street
Journal the White House and now one of
the largest financial institutions in
the world where I lead sustainable
investing now these institutions are
like tankers and working inside of them
I've come to appreciate what large
weights they can leave and I've become
convinced that the institution of the
global capital markets the nearly 290
trillion dollars in stocks and bonds in
the world that that may be one of our
most powerful forces for positive social
change at our disposal if we ask it to
be now I know some of you are thinking
global capital markets positive social
change not usually in the same sentence
or even the same paragraph I think many
people think of the capital markets kind
of like an ocean
it's a vast impersonal uncaring force of
nature that is not affected by our
wishes or desires
so the best that our little savings
accounts the retirement accounts can do
is to try to catch some waves and the
good cycles and hope that we don't get
inundated in the turbulent ones but
certainly our decisions on how to steer
our little retirement accounts don't
affect the tides don't change the shape
or size or direction of the waves but
why is that because actually one third
of this ocean of capital is actually
belongs to individuals by us and most of
the rest of the capital markets is
controlled by the institutions that get
their power and authority and their
capital from us as members participants
beneficiaries shareholders or citizens
so if we are the ultimate owners of the
capital markets why aren't we able to
make our voices heard why can't we make
some waves so let me ask you a different
question did any of you buy Fairtrade
coffee the last time you heard a
supermarket or at Starbucks okay do any
of you go to the restaurant and order of
a sustainably farmed trout instead of
the miso-glazed Chilean sea bass you
really wish you could have do it if you
drive hybrid cars or even electric cars
so why do we do these things right one
electric car doesn't amount to much in
the fleet of 1.2 billion combustion
engine vehicles one fish is just one
fish in the sea and one cup of coffee
doesn't amount to hill of beans in this
crazy world but we do these things
because we believe they matter that our
actions add up that our choices might
influence others and collectively what
an impact we can have so in my bag I
have a coffee mug that I bought a couple
of years ago it's a reusable mug and has
all these things printed on it look at
what some of the things that are on it
that it says this one cup can be used
again again this one cup may inspire
others to use one to this one cup helps
save the planet I ignored yeah this
plastic cup was so powerful so why do we
think that our choice of $4 she'd grown
fair trade artisanal cup of coffee in a
reusable mug matters but what we do is
four thousand dollars in our invest
cat for our IRA doesn't why can't we
tell the supermarket and the capital
markets that we care that would care
about Fair Labor Standards that we care
about the similar production methods and
about healthy communities why aren't we
voting with our investment dollars the
way we vote with our lattes so I think
it has something to do with a myths of
Fable so we all carry Ryan in our
collective consciousness you remember
the Grimm's fairy tale about the magic
porridge pot he said to the pot boil
it'll pop boil it would fill up with
sweet porridge he said stop little pot
stop it would stop but you got the words
wrong it wouldn't listen and things
could go terribly awry so I think when
it comes to markets I think we have a
little bit of a similar fable in our
heads we believe it's a markets is this
magic pot that obeys only one command
make more money only those words said
exactly that way will make the pot fill
up with gold add in some extra Wars like
protect the environment spell might not
work put in the wrong words like promote
social justice and you might see you a
cold coins shrink or even vanished
entirely the core is disabled so we ask
people what do you really think and we
actually went out and pulled a thousand
individual investors and we found
something fascinating overwhelmingly
people wanted to add those extra words
into the formula 71% of people said yes
they were interested in sustainable
investing which we define is taking the
best-in-class investment process that
you already have traditionally and
adding in the extra information you get
when you think about the environment and
society and good governs 71% wanted them
72% said that they believe the companies
he did that would actually do better
financially so people really do believe
that you can do well by doing good but
here was the weird thing 54% of the
people still said if they put their
money in those kinds of stocks they
thought that they would make less money
so is it true do you get less sweet
porridge
if you
vestan shade-grown coffee instead of
drinking it well you know the investors
and companies like Burt's Bees or Ben
and Jerry's wouldn't say so right both
of those started out as small socially
conscious companies that ended up
becoming so popular with consumers that
the Giants Unilever and Clorox bought
them for hundreds of millions dollars
each but here's the important thing
those corporations realized that if they
wanted to protect the value of their
investments they had to preserve that
socially conscious mission if they
didn't keep adding in those extra words
of environmentally friendly and socially
conscious those brands wouldn't make
more money but maybe this is just the
exception that proves the rule
right in the serious companies that fund
our economy and that fund our
retirements and that really make the
walk-arounds they need to stick to
making more money so Harvard Business
School actually researched this and they
found something fascinating if you had
invested a dollar 20 years ago in a
portfolio of companies that focused
narrowly on making more money quarter by
quarter that $1 would have grown to $14
and 46 cents that's not bad until you
consider that if instead you didn't dust
that same dollar and a portfolio of
companies that focus on growing their
business and on the most important
environmental and social issues that one
dollar would have grown to $28 and 36
cents almost twice as much as sweet
porridge now let's be clear they didn't
make that out performance by giving away
money to seem like a nice corporate
citizen they did it by focusing on the
things that mattered to their business
like wasting less energy and water in
their manufacturing processes like
making sure that the CEO contracts have
the CEOs incentivize for the long-term
results of the company and the
communities they served not just
quarterly results or building a
first-class culture that would have
higher employee loyalty retention and
productivity
now Harvard's not alone Oxford also did
a research study where they examined 100
different studies looking at the effect
of sustainability and economic results
and they found time and time and time
again that the companies that cared
about these kinds of important things
actually had better operational
efficiency lower cost of capital and
better performance in their stock price
and then there's al gore so 20 years ago
when I worked for Al Gore in the White
House he was one of the early pioneers
pleading with businesses and governments
to pay attention to the challenges of
climate change post White House he
opened an investment forum called
generation where he baked environmental
sustainability and other things right
into the core investment process and at
the time there was bit of skepticism
about his views ten years later his
track record is one more proof point
that sustainable investing done right
can be sound investing far from making
less a sweet porridge because he added
sustainability into the mix he actually
significantly outperformed the benchmark
now sustainable investing the good news
is it doesn't require a magic spell and
it doesn't acquire some investment
secret and it's not just for the elite
it is not just about private equity for
billionaires it's not just groovy
sounding investments like clean
technology or a microfinance and
emerging markets or artisanal bakeries
in Brooklyn it's about stocks and bonds
and fortune 500 companies it's not a
mutual fund it's about all the things we
already see in the markets today so
here's why and I'm convinced that we
collectively have the power to make
sustainable investing the new normal
first the proof points are coming out
all the time that sustainable investing
done right preserving all the same good
principles of investing the traditional
sphere can pay it makes sense
secondly the biggest obstacle standing
our way may actually just be in our
heads we just need to let go with that
myth that if you add your values into
your investment thinking that you get
less sweet porridge and once you get rid
of the fable you can actually start
appreciating those facts we've been
talking about and third the futures
already here
sustainable investing today is a 20
trillion dollar market and it's the
fastest-growing segment of the
investment industry and the United
States has grown enormously as you can
see it now represents one out of every
six dollars under professional
management in the United States so what
are we waiting for
for me it goes back to the inspiration I
received for my mother she knew that she
wanted her life where she would have the
freedom to make her own choices and to
have her voice heard and write her own
story she was passionate about that goal
and she was clear that she would let no
army no obstacle no big institution
stand in her way
she made it to the States and she became
a teacher an award-winning author and a
mother and ended up sending her
daughters to Harvard and these days you
can tell that she is amply comfortable
holding court and the most powerful
institutions in the world it seems
almost too pathetic that her name in
Korean means fashion clarity passionate
clarity that's what I think we need to
drive change passion about the change we
want to see in the world and clarity
that we are able to help chart the
course we have more opportunity today
than ever before
to make choices we have more power than
ever before to make our voices heard
so change your perspective vote with
your small change invest in the change
you want to see in the world change the
Sables and change the markets thank you
you